Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
el día de hoy los llevaremos a Estados
Unidos desde el medio oeste hasta el Sur
para analizar los temas que podrían
determinar las elecciones de medio
término será este 8 de noviembre cuando
se definirá quienes ocuparán las 435
sillas a la cámara de representantes y
las 35 sillas al senado además se
conocerá quién quedará al mando de las
36 gobernaciones entre otras elecciones
locales y estatales que definirán la
agenda política del país nuestra
reportera Fania lark en un recorrido a
lo largo del río Mississippi entrevistó
a diferentes estadounidenses para
conocer sus opiniones sobre los tópicos
que influirán en los comicios entre
ellos la reforma de la policía las armas
el aborto la economía y la crisis
climática veamos el reportaje
[Música]
en mayo de 2020 emineápolis se convirtió
en el símbolo de la violencia policial
en Estados Unidos tras el asesinado de
George Floyd a manos de un agente de
policía blanco desde entonces al menos
otros cuatro hombres negros desarmados
han sido asesinados por la policía de la
ciudad entre ellos Donkey wright de 20
años que fue abatido durante un control
de tráfico en abril de 2021
tenía la piel Clara y aún así la policía
lo perfiló racialmente
y en un millón de años pensé que nos
pasaría algo así
no somos pandilleros ni le hacemos daño
a nadie
somos gente decente eso no debió
habernos pasado
intentó huir de los policías King Potter
un policía con 26 años de experiencia le
disparó fatalmente la gente que afirmó
haber confundido su arma con una pistola
de descarga eléctrica fue declarada
culpable de homicidio culposo
Definitivamente hay un problema con la
forma en la que la policía está
entrenada la forma en que todo funciona
si mi hijo hubiera tenido el cabello
rubio y los ojos azules probablemente
seguiría vivo desde 2020 cerca de un
tercio de los policías de Minneapolis
han abandonado la institución el
departamento de policía ha introducido
cambios patrullas Sin armas jornadas
laborales más cortas y un énfasis en
recuperar la confianza de la comunidad
he tenido la firme intención de llegar a
las comunidades porque muchas de ellas
no nos conocen solo ven el uniforme Así
que cuando nos ven Piensan en lo que
ocurrió en 2020 pero no todos somos así
Nosotros también somos personas
a principios de este año el departamento
de derechos humanos de Minnesota publicó
un duro informe que mostraba que el
departamento de policía de Minneapolis
Tenía un patrón de discriminación racial
cuando el informe salió me molestó dice
que tenemos un patrón de discriminación
Pero eso no es lo que veo aquí ni lo que
hacen estos oficiales ni lo que hago yo
es cierto que existe ese incidente
tenemos algunos antecedentes no entiendo
pero personalmente No creo que eso nos
represente no es lo que intentamos hacer
en mayo firmó una orden ejecutiva que
ordenaba los organismos federales
encargados de hacer cumplir la ley que
revisar a las políticas de uso de la
fuerza según los críticos no se aplica a
las 18.000 agencias estatales y locales
del país
llegó con la energía del movimiento
Black lives se reunió con la familia de
George Floyd pero todavía no ha probado
una legislación significativa de
responsabilidad policial necesitan que
los hombres negros salgan a votar los
hombres negros necesitamos justicia
económica y que la policía deje de
matarnos Así que si un candidato puede
asegurar eso entonces podemos votar por
él sino Entonces vamos a mirar hacia
otra dirección a pesar de constituir
alrededor del 13% de la población los
negros siguen representando el 25% de
las víctimas mortales de la policía este
año una disparidad que podría costarle a
los demócratas parte del crucial voto
afroamericano ahora vamos a Wisconsin
donde el aborto se ha convertido en algo
casi ilegal Sam White tiene 23 años
quedó embarazada en mayo y tenía la cita
para abortar el día en el que el
tribunal supremo de Estados Unidos anuló
la sentencia de rock contra White mi
amiga iba a llevarme llegó a mi casa
teníamos todas mis cosas listas para ir
y recibió una notificación en mi
teléfono diciendo que Row había sido
anulado
justo después recibió una llamada de
planificación familiar
y me dijeron que no podían atenderme
porque el aborto en Wisconsin era
inmediatamente ilegal me molestó el
impacto que tuve en el país
pero también el impacto que tuvo en mi
personalmente
trabaja por las noches como mesera para
pagar sus estudios por lo que no habría
podido criar a un niño por sí sola a
pesar de las dificultades pudo llegar al
vecino estado de Minnesota para
interrumpir su embarazo
fue muy duro para mí pero al mismo
tiempo estoy en la universidad tengo una
educación tengo un trabajo tengo un auto
tengo privilegios fue una situación
horrible pero no podría imaginarme pasar
por eso sin algunos de esos privilegios
diría que de todos los problemas a los
que se enfrenta nuestro país los
derechos de las mujeres son el principal
en virtud de una ley Estatal de 1849 que
está siendo contestada en los tribunales
es un delito grave practicar un aborto
excepto cuando la vida su madre está en
peligro sin excepciones en caso de
violación o incesto un retroceso en los
derechos de las mujeres que ha
enardecido a los activistas de Cara a
las elecciones legislativas del 8 de
noviembre
Hoy estamos hablando con los vecinos
para ver cómo se sienten después de la
reciente decisión de la Corte Suprema
que anuló Rose
algunos caminos para restaurar los
servicios de aborto legal en Wisconsin
tengo miedo pero me da Esperanza saber
que hay gente dispuesta a luchar por lo
que todos merecemos
planificación familiar planeaba gastar
un récord de 50 millones de dólares para
impulsar a la población a votar por
partidarios del derecho al aborto en
todo el país hay políticos a los que les
gustaría ver eso regulado mantenerla
como ley local en Wisconsin Así que es
importante desde nuestro punto de vista
que elijamos Defensores de la salud
reproductiva que luchen por restaurar
ese acceso y hagan lo que puedan a nivel
legislativo oficial para restaurar el
acceso a esa atención sanitaria esencial
durante el verano una oleada de
inscripciones femeninas hizo que las
nuevas votantes de Wisconsin superarán a
los hombres en 17 puntos y los
demócratas pusieron sus esperanzas en
convertir el aborto en el tema central
de las elecciones de medio término a 800
kilómetros al sur se encuentra la
segunda ciudad más grande de Missouri
hasta hace poco San Luis tenía el
sombrío título de capital de asesinatos
de Estados Unidos y aún tiene la segunda
tasa de homicidios más alta del país
este padre de cuatro hijos lo sabe muy
bien su hija mayor fue asesinada en
agosto mientras manejaba fue alcanzada
por una bala perdida
Supuestamente iba manejando en medio de
un tiroteo no estaba haciendo nada malo
no estaba involucrada en la situación
solo estaba manejando dacia Bauer tenía
25 años y una hija de 5 años es una de
las casi 160 Víctimas de la violencia
arma San Luis este año su padre cree que
se necesita urgentemente un mayor
control de las armas
somos simplemente irresponsables por
esta epidemia que tenemos con las armas
en este país si no tenemos una reforma
integral de las armas y no presionamos a
nuestros representantes y a nuestros
funcionarios públicos
si no hacemos algo constantemente habrá
personas heridas y asesinadas sin
sentido
Misuri tiene la quinta tasa más alta de
muertes por armas de fuego en el país
también tiene algunas de las leyes de
control de armas más lactas el estado no
tiene una edad mínima para comprar un
arma de fuego y cualquiera que pueda
poseer legalmente un arma puede portarla
abiertamente sin un permiso completa la
sección B del formulario
empieza ahí con tu nombre lugar de
nacimiento ciudad y estado puedes
abreviar el estado altura peso sexo
fecha de nacimiento necesito dígitos y
cuatro los vendedores con licencia como
less steinberg tienen que cumplir la ley
federal que exige una comprobación de
antecedentes pero para los
distribuidores sin licencia en el estado
no hay tales a requisitos Creo que
muchas de las cosas que se oyen en
cuanto al uso de un arma de fuego de
forma inapropiada no son cometidas por
propietarios honestos
las leyes son respetadas por la gente
honesta creo que son ignoradas pero
muchos otros
ante el aumento de la violencia con
armas de fuego los estadounidenses están
de acuerdo en la necesidad de un cambio
pero no en la solución los demócratas
creen que la respuesta es un mayor
control de las armas mientras que los
republicanos sostienen que la clave será
endurecimiento de las medidas policiales
dejamos el medio oeste y nos dirigimos
más al sur a Tennessee el hogar del
blues se vio muy afectado por la
pandemia ahora Memphis y sus residentes
tienen que lidiar con la creciente
inflación Sandy ochmani dirige un
negocio de alquiler de vehículos en la
ciudad Hola
Te llamaba para confirmar que hoy Te
recogen a las 3 por primera vez en 20
años Tuvo que subir sus tarifas horarias
en 15 dólares debido al aumento del
precio de la gasolina no es solo la
gasolina el precio del seguro ha subido
el precio de los vehículos ha subido
incluso las bebidas que ponemos en el
auto para los clientes han subido las
servilletas todo ha subido
la inflación ha empeorado tanto las
cosas que ahora está considerando vender
su empresa por ahora sin embargo trata
de mantener el gasto en gasolina tan
Bajo como puede
vamos a probar esta estación de shell
debería valerme 5 centavos menos como
mínimo ahora usamos diferentes tarjetas
de crédito que nos dan descuentos por
galón el precio de la gasolina regular
es bastante bueno
en el sur la inflación alcanzó casi el
9% de septiembre casi medio punto
porcentual más que la tasa nacional
josmani culpa a los demócratas de su
problema cada vez que hemos tenido un
presidente republicano al país parece
irle muy bien
para todos sus problemas dirigió el país
como un negocio
y eso estaba funcionando la inflación no
solo es dura para las pequeñas empresas
también está causando estragos entre los
agricultores Marvin rory cultivazo ya en
las afueras de Memphis en El delta del
Mississippi pero este año está operando
con pérdidas cultivó aproximadamente 300
Acres y mis gastos operativos pasaron de
unos 200 dólares
acre a 300
320 dólares acre Solo quiero ser capaz
de producir un producto de calidad Pero
al final del día obtener ganancias para
ganar nuestras cuentas como agricultores
la inflación ha empeorado desde la
guerra en Ucrania los precios del
combustible y los fertilizantes se han
duplicado
para mantenerse a flote Brody depende de
sus compañeros agricultores
intentamos utilizar algunos equipos
que puede que yo tenga y que él no
en vez de comprar los dos las mismas
cosas Tratamos de reducir los gastos
las encuestas recientes han mostrado
sistemáticamente que la economía y la
inflación son de lejos la prioridad
número uno para los votantes
estadounidenses y entre esos votantes la
mayoría confía más en los republicanos
para arreglar la economía la última
parada en el río Mississippi es Luisiana
fundada por colonos franceses hace más
de 300 años Nueva Orleans estaba
amenazada por fenómenos meteorológicos
extremos para protegerse de Los
Huracanes la ciudad invirtió 14,500
millones de dólares en un nuevo sistema
de diques
no es un sistema 100% Perfecto es un
sistema de reducción de riesgos el
cambio climático hace que todo el sur de
Louisiana sea más vulnerable la ciudad
ahora Está rodeada por un muro de 560
kilómetros de largo y 8 metros de alto
el sistema pasó su primera gran prueba
en 2021 con el huracán ida Pero sigue
siendo frágil a los diques hay que
realizarles mantenimiento continuamente
aquí se puede ver la parte del muro de
contención que se está hundiendo
en esta parte y esta parte estaba
niveladas y ahora hay probablemente unos
5 centímetros de desplazamiento Los
Huracanes no son la única amenaza a toda
la costa de Luisiana se enfrenta también
a la subida del nivel del mar y los
expertos advierten que esta podría ser
de unos 60 centímetros para 2050 Si
miran el agua de allá verán que hay
muchos árboles muertos
Esto fue una vez un bosque de Cipreses Y
eso le proporcionado a Nueva Orleans un
amortiguador natural contra las
tormentas y los huracanes y el agua
para hacer frente a la creciente amenaza
a las empresas locales intentan
encontrar soluciones esta empresa
recicla el vidrio de la ciudad para
convertirlo en Arena con la esperanza de
frenar la erosión del litoral traemos
unas 15 toneladas de vidrio a la semana
todo lo que se tritura cae en un embudo
el material pesado cae directamente al
fondo en esta bolsa de aquí
este es nuestro principal producto
luego la arena se transfiere a sacos de
yute y que se descomponen en seis meses
y permiten que el nuevo material se
mezcle con el medio ambiente
hasta ahora aquí han sido recicladas
1.250 toneladas de vidrio
el estado de Luisiana pierde un campo de
fútbol cada 100 minutos aproximadamente
no podemos reemplazar eso pero podemos
desplegar estratégicamente nuestro
material para ralentizar la erosión
los residentes van tres veces por semana
dejar sus botellas de vidrio Qué impacto
tiene realmente 40.000 libras
depende del entorno si se despliegan
bien 10.000 libras de arena pueden
cambiar la trayectoria de un pantano
la restauración de la costa ha sido algo
por lo que luchamos en Luisiana toda mi
vida hemos discutido sobre ello
Así que cuando uno ve de primera mano
como desaparece es un shock estos chicos
libran esa batalla la forma en que mucho
Esa batalla es dejando el vidrio acá y
votando el 8 de noviembre los votantes
de Luisiana y de todo el país emitirán
sus votos Aunque cerca de la mitad de
ellos dice que el cambio climático es
importante muy por detrás de otros temas
como la economía el aborto o la
delincuencia
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para visualizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]